Hi, I'm Christopher Simone and I'm the Scoutmaster of Troop 71 in Plendome, New
York. This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
I had a little gentleman's wager with my Scouts because I told them I could jump
higher than any house And they said: there is absolutely no way that you
could do that. And I said: well, you know, if you want to have a little wager on
that, that's fine. And they said, yep, okay, So if you win the next camping trip, we'll
set up your tent, And if you don't win the next camping trip, you set up our
tents. And I said that sounds good to me. And they said, okay, so how are you
gonna prove this? And I said: well, it's easy. You go home this week and you
measure how high your house can jump, Okay, And then come back next week And I
guarantee you I'll be able to jump higher than your house does. Guess I
don't have to set up my tent next camping trip. Hey, this is podcast number
292..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Thanks, Bill
McFarlane, for the idea, for the joke. I suppose it was a joke at the head of
the podcast. Oh, let's see here. So hey, if it gets noisy in the background, we
got some guys working on the house this week. Oh my goodness, If you
live in an old house, who you better watch out, Because as soon as you
start working on one part of it, an old house is kind of like a
sweater: You start pulling on one thread and the whole thing comes
unraveled. So it might be a little noisy in the background this week,
but don't worry about it, Everything's fine. Let's take a look in the
mailbag. We heard from James Montigny is a scout master with
Troop 1124 in Raymore, Missouri, And he wrote this: I wanted to take
a moment to thank you for all the hard work that you put into
enabling scouts and scouters. My life scout and I listen to your
podcast regularly and we share what we learn with our Troop So
well. the older scouts and parents have started tuning in to the
guidance. encouragement that we get from people like you are
exactly what I needed as a new scout master. Your books- so far
so good- maybe you feel a little less alone while trying to
convince people that this was the way it was meant to be. your
PDF resources frequently find a way into my training sessions
with both youth and adults, and district roundtable sessions. I'm
pleased to report that in two short years of having a youth led
troop, we're doing very well. We've grown from five to almost
40. Wow, James, that's pretty impressive numbers there,
including many scouts who had previously left other programs
and found renewed passion with scouting for us. They plant
the scouts, plan and execute their own meetings, outings, courts
of honor, service projects and even gather information in book
event sites. They greet weevilos, welcome them into the
troop at blue and gold events and give me plenty of time on
my rocking chair in the back of the room. They recently
elected their senior patrol leader and he emceed a
spectacular Eagle Court of Honor for one of his peers today,
and I could not be more proud of my scouts. The concept has
led over into the pack, where dent chiefs are taking
leadership roles, managing activities and promoting the
idea that youth have a say in deciding what they're going
to do, and the scouts are having more fun and retention has
been even higher. Recreating adult leadership has been
easier, especially when they see that they have experienced
scouts ready to take the lead. If that wasn't enough,
we've even spawned a venturing crew, Our young men and
young women in the crew quickly filled the leadership
ranks and took charge of their unit of witness. tremendous
growth within those young people in six short months. as a
result, Imagine that boys who've been Eagles for four or
five years still active in supporting the next generation
of scouts, Girls- something new to scouting, some with
silver and gold awards, getting involved and taking on
leadership roles and having an absolute blast. Thank you,
sir. I cannot express how much I appreciate what you've
done and thank you, James. That's what we call a paycheck
right there. When you hear that people are making use of
what you're doing, it just makes it all worthwhile,
doesn't it? Speaking of so far, so good, and that's my
book about being a new scout master. It's an easy read,
It's pretty easy to get to. It's over on Amazon and
I'll tell you how to get it from my website in just
a moment. But over on Amazon, Rick gave so far, so
good a five star review. It said it's great for new
scout master. Then I had this email from Tim Clark,
who's an assistant scout master with Selma Troop
343, and he was writing about a republished post that
I put on Facebook this past week called Doing What
Scouts Do, and, incidentally, that's what we're going
to be talking about in today's podcast. Tim had
listened to last week's podcast and he wrote this:
said amen. I listened to your podcast yesterday
about a scouts dilemma, about not having enough
time for scouting and the pressure to excel. Your
message about doing what scouts do speaks volumes
to exactly that situation. My oldest son is
currently working on his leadership project. I'm
finding the trail of paperwork more challenging
than his project, which is already challenging
at his own choosing. Well, Tim, I'm glad you
found that useful. and really, enough with the
Eagle paperwork, right? I mean enough already.
There's enough paperwork for Eagle. Let's not,
let's not add anymore. Okay, Every week on
Tuesday and Wednesday mornings, usually we
have a live chat session over at scoutmastercgcom
and, in addition to all of the frequent fliers who
checked in, this week we heard also from Matt
Thompson, who's a member of a troop committee in
Eureka, Kansas. So thanks for checking in with us,
Matt. Look, before I go any further, everything
at scoutmastercgcom and this podcast is there
to help you as a scouter, and I hear from
folks- actually believe it or not- all over the
world who tell me that it manages to help
them. So to keep everything freely available
for everyone. I depend on people like you to
become backers. It's an unusual idea, So let
me explain. If I was sending you- I don't
know- a paper magazine or a newsletter or
something like that, you'd expect there to be
costs associated with that. right, I'd have
to pay somebody to print it and I'd have to
pay writers and postage. But what I'm doing
is actually kind of similar, because
somebody spends their time producing all of
this and encourage the expenses of
publishing it, and backers are the folks
who make a one-time kind of voluntary
subscription payment and that money goes to
help me cover the expense of producing and
publishing and creating everything that
you find at scoutmastercgcom. So this
week I would appreciate it if you could go
and become a backer. It's really easy to
do. Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the
support link at the top of the page and
you'll find a number of options that will
make you a scoutmastercgcom backer. And
this week I want to personally thank Steve
Quinones, Tim Grimmie, John Keeler,
Christopher Simone and Michael Land, who
all became backers since our last
podcast. Once again, really easy to do. Go
to scoutmastercgcom, click the
support link, become a backer this week
and I'll thank you during our next
podcast. Well, in the remainder of this
week's podcast I am going to describe
something that is the answer to every
question that I've ever had as a
scouter, The answer to every question
that I've ever gotten by email since I
started writing scoutmastercgcom 10
years ago. it's the Silver Bullet, It's
the idea of the base principle that
takes care of just about everything we
encounter as scouters And that is
going to take up the remainder of the
podcast. So let's get started, shall we?
Oh, I'm in love with the man who loves to
camp. He camps when it's sunny, he
camps when it's damp. All he needs is
a tent, a sleeping roll, a package of
hot dogs and a sack of charcoal. He
camps in the desert. he camps in the
snow. He says: baby, come with me.
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
So imagine this for a moment. okay,
Let's imagine there's nothing called
scouting. There's no program, no
troops, no councils, no districts, no
uniforms, no badges. But somebody comes
up with this idea of helping young
people develop character by getting
outdoors and going camping. And then
they share this idea with young people
who get pretty excited about it, and
they get their buddies together and
they decide they'd really like the
whole idea and they organize a
camping trip, And the whole idea is
built on a set of shared ideals that
encourages everyone to treat each other
decently and helps everybody work
together. So as they share this idea
and as they go camping, other young
people get pretty excited about it.
They get their buddies together, they
decide they really like the idea and
they go on a camping trip. And this
just happens over and over and over
again. And in order for everybody to
go camping comfortably, there are
a number of new skills that they need
to develop And there is a way to
recognize being proficient in those
skills. There's a structured set of
responsibilities that are aimed at
coordinating and completing the chores
of planning and carrying out a
camping trip, And there aren't really
many forms or paperwork. There's
enough to keep track of things and to
assist planning and and communicating,
And the young people come up against
a lot of challenges, but they resolve
them by applying the ideals that this
whole idea is braced on. Things aren't
always organized. No, they're not.
Sometimes it's kind of a mess.
There's plenty of room for improvement
in just about everything, but the
young people involved love what
they're doing, because what they're
doing is they're doing what scouts
do. Now, if we focus on doing what
scouts do, we'll always do the right
thing. If we get ourselves caught up in
the thicket of policies and procedures
and logistics and traditions and
people saying, well, this is the way
that we always done it, And the idea
that, well, getting recognition for
this is what's really important, And
the idea of sweeping together as
many merit badges as you possibly
can, and the idea of achievement over
everything else, If we get ourselves
caught in all of that, what we're
doing really is we're coming at the
whole thing from the wrong direction.
Things like policies, procedures,
planning, advancement, awards, programs-
they only make sense when we do what
scouts do. When scouts get to do the
things scouts do, all of that other
stuff happens as an after effect.
They advance as an after effect. When
scouts do requirements, they check
things off in a book, right. A true
breakthrough for all of us as
scouts is to understand doing
requirements is nothing to do with
scouting. Completing requirements are
an after effect of doing what What
scouts do right. And when we do what
scouts do, our scouts have real
breakthroughs. They really understand
the concepts and the skills And
that's worth doing a thousand
requirements. So our concentration
ought to be doing what scouts do.
That's the secret, right, That's the
secret to the entire thing, because
that's how we started out And then
a lot of things got overlaid on it-
Big organizations and different
levels of management and
administration of those
organizations- But when it comes
down to it, scouting is all about
what scouts do. And when they do the
things that scouts do, what happens
is we build character. that happens
pretty naturally and they advance
pretty naturally. Think about a
camping trip. Scouts go camping and
while they're camping, they cook the
food that they selected, purchased
and packed right. They light camp
fires, they set up tents and tarps.
they build things with sticks and
string. they learn how to
experience the natural world without
leaving a trace. they learn how to
use edge tools safely. You know,
when scouts go swimming and boating,
doing the things that scouts do, they
learn how to swim better. They learn
how to paddle canoe or row a row boat.
They learn about safety in and on the
water. They learn how to aid people
and distress on the water. When
they're participating citizens and
serving their communities, they learn
about their community and the way
it's governed. They serve in various
ways. They learn how to be
responsible and to use resources and
technology responsibly, how to act
and to react with others with
decency and character. They learn
about their nation and community and
families, history and traditions. When
scouts go on hikes, they learn to read
and follow maps, to use compasses and
GPS units, to learn and practice
safe hiking skills. When they help
other people, they render first aid,
they respond to emergencies, they
support the needy- I mean, I could go
on and on and on. It's about doing
what scouts do. Everything else
about scouting, everything else, is
just window dressing. It's just
there. It's not as important. It
follows when you do what scouts do.
but it's not why we're doing scouting.
We're not doing scouting so scouts
advance. We're not doing scouting.
earn merit badges or even learn
special skills and things like that.
We're doing scouting so that they
can do what scouts do, because when
scouts do what scouts do,
everything else works. Everything else
happens. It's pretty simple, but that's
really the secret of the whole thing.
Well, thanks for listening to this
290-second edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast. Here's how you're going to keep
in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email. by the
way,
You can also join all the people who
follow us through the vast panorama
of social media. You can join the
10,600 folks that like Scoutmaster
blog on Facebook. Tweet along with
the chorus of something like
1,300 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the Pultritudinous pictures that are
proper publicly
with 2,400 other prolific pinners on
Pinterest.
You can watch us at ScoutmasterCG on
YouTube.
but you say
I can't face Facebook and Twitter
makes me better
and I have no interest in Pinterest
and I don't put the? U in YouTube. Well,
that's
okay.
Just zoom into the late 90s and
fire off a good old-fashioned
email:
Contact me, Clark Green at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
Now, if all else fails,
write your message
or question on a piece of paper, seal
it in a bottle and bury it in any
campfire circle,
because I have agents everywhere and
I'll be sure to get it.
By now. there should be little doubt
that the Scoutmaster blog and
Scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other Scouting
organization for that matter.
No,
It is only me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along
the way, and speaking of fun,
here is our founder, Sir Robert
Bidden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone
you.